I'm from Boston yeah I'm from this
really racist part of Boston called
Boston and I'm an Orthodox Jew yeah I've
never had bacon I'm that kind of Jew
I've never tried bacon I've tried
cocaine but I've never tried babe that's
the life I've had my real name isn't
Alec settlement my real name get ready
is double Yosef shamone been of lows
eruvin Haleiwa Alex Edelman I go by Alex
because it's all I can remember and like
I get a lot of crap for not going by my
real name like my family gives me a lot
of [ __ ] for it they're like why do you
do buy a real name huh you know proud of
your real name and I'm like no my dad's
name is Eleazar I'll be like what quite
a real name and I'm like I don't know
Eleazar because it sounds like we're all
in Slytherin that's why I have cousins
Menachem and Yitzhak you can't even
spell their names in English because
there's no English letter for phlegm
I have a twin brothers will have a twin
brother AJ my twin brother is a
professional bodybuilder
my twin brother is a professional
bodybuilder and people are like are you
guys identical twins and I'm like we
used to be now we look like a before and
after photo he lives in New York with
two cats and no neck I live in New York
I moved there I moved there to go to
college I went to New York University
and I didn't know this until I got there
on the first day NYU has no campus there
is no canvas and this I found I just
dropped my stuff off at the dorm on the
first day and I said where's the campus
in the RA it was like what and I said
where does the quad and this is what you
did I'll never forget this UN Alex the
city is your campus
and I said to them I was like I don't
know if you know this man but I did a
Google and last year there were 188
murders on campus my first job in New
York I worked at KFC I worked at gave
zero three weeks which is the longest
anyone has ever worked at a can say I
have a pension and what you're supposed
to do when someone walks into a KFC is
say can I help you
the KFC that I worked at was in Penn
Station in New York and I worked the
1:00 a.m. to 8:00 a.m. shift one o'clock
in the morning in a fast-food restaurant
in Penn Station can I help you is not
good customer service
it's a promise you can't keep
I never mind and sad people by the way
you should be sad it's a KFC you should
be devastated that you're in there the
people I minded were like happy white
hipsters who would come in like it was a
real restaurant and they'd say things
like what's your healthy option and I'd
be like leaving that's our healthy
option you should be the same as the
employees who work there when you go
into a fast-food restaurant you're
unhappy were unhappy you're gross were
gross
you're not wearing gloves were not
wearing class this woman came in once
and she was at least 300 pounds and she
had the meanest expression I've ever
seen and I said can I help you and she
went I don't know can yell and I didn't
know what to say to that I just wanted
Oh chicken oh well what would you like
and she went
I don't know and I said well what are
you feeling which is also the wrong
question cuz she goes well tired and I'm
homesick and I miss my family what do
you think I should get you little
[ __ ] because I was like 18 and I had
no training and I had no other options
and I really wanted to help I was like
if you miss your family we have a family
buck heads alright thanks so much guys
[Applause]
you